and the great thing about it is we get
to
experience the innovation that this
industry has to offer and it
really fuels us and keeps us going
[Music]
thank you for being on my show how are
you i'm well michael thank you for
having me appreciate it
i am very excited to have you i came in
here thinking we're going to talk
primarily about consulting and mk
insights and mba and finance
but we're going to start off with
education because the first thing that
you told me is that this is something
you're
particularly passionate about and and
intertwined with your
passion now for for uh helping
bridge gaps in education i'd love to tie
this also to your personal journey
and to understand a little bit about
where you come from and
sort of the non-linear career pathway
that you took to
to found to becoming the ceo of the very
successful mka insight so kiran who are
you
well i don't know if 20 minutes will
suffice for a life history here but
i'll it never does but we'll try
so education is absolutely something i'm
extremely passionate about it's one of
my core tenets
it has molded me it has driven me
continues to drive me today
um you know i'm a constant learner i
want to absorb as much knowledge as i
can i ask a ton of questions and
that's been me for as long as i can
recall
um and it really started um
a very long time ago when i came to this
country
i was about five years old my parents
emigrated here from
pakistan um they had six children at the
time they had
a seventh child that was born in the
state so i'm one of seven
where in pakistan by the way um so we
moved around a little bit but
um hyderabad and karachi are kind of the
two towns
that my parents hail from wow and
um you know my parents always brought us
here and said there are no opportunities
or few opportunities in pakistan but
in america with an education you can be
anything
and do anything you want to be the
american dream
american dream true and i'm i'm five
years old i'm listening to my parents
not fully realizing what that means
until um you know i i realize very early
on and i have
high logic centers i think you know
how does this work you know those are
the questions that
drive me and so i would ask well why
does the grass grow how does the sun
revolve around the earth and
the responses i got were very religious
because my parents are very conservative
and they would say well god does this
and god does that
and i would go well i don't know like i
think there's a
there's a response here and so i
at a very early age was
six years old by six years old i knew i
was born into the wrong family
i was very scientific oriented wanted to
know how the world works and the
responses i was getting wasn't feeding
that intellectual curiosity
and i remembered my father said i
brought you here for an education with
an education you can
do anything be anything and i held on to
that
i believed it i started accelerating in
school i had just a natural ability i
love academics i love books
so i accelerated and you know i knew
that that was my
ticket out of there it wasn't just the
religious
household that i butted heads with i
grew up you know six
seven kids in a really impoverished part
of town just outside of philadelphia we
did not have a lot
and i knew that education was my way out
of there
for multiple reasons and so i applied
myself
and you know put myself through school
and continued to focus on education and
that's allowed me
to make the jumps that i have had in my
career
and allowing me to be where i am today
so education is a
core tenant of mine i truly believe
that with education you can do and be
anything you want to be but you have to
believe in it
i have a few quick questions so so out
of the out of the seven children where
are you
and you're definitely not the youngest
but where are you and the in the line i
am the exact
middle child i am the fourth child in
the social order
wonderful and and your favorite subjects
in school
oh well of course science and math so
i'm a stem child
growing up um there's order it's
tangible you know there's it's
predictable
it's predictable you know it right
there's always an answer to it i always
struggled with history
and writing but reading was also a
favorite of mine so i was
an absolute book worm growing up
wonderful
okay so you see you go through college
at your
bachelor's your master's and then mba
and then
and then what what's your thinking
process so what so where do you go from
there because you both studied finance
as a master's
but you've done your also business
degree so so what's next for you
so wrapping up my finance and business
degree
um i ended up getting a job out of
business school with a life sciences
tools company
and ended up doing m a work for them
and it wasn't what i thought i was going
to do because i
graduated in um 2009
which was just at the height of the
housing bubble
bursting and so there was a flood of
financial professionals
and prior to going to business school
i had a very different career than i um
than post business school so i worked in
politics
for about three and a half years i
earned a degree in economics
and it's not the degree that i thought i
was going to get being a
child i thought i was going to go into
some kind of medical field
and unfortunately that did not work out
you know the bookworm that was removed
from her
very conservative household where we
weren't allowed to do very much
transplanted over to southern california
with the beaches and just the beautiful
weather
and for the very first time in my life i
experienced life for the very first time
so i don't know if
i would take any of the life experiences
back i would certainly go back and tell
my younger self to
pay more attention to the organic
chemistry and the biology books and
maybe
try and finish out that scientific
degree but that was not in the cards for
me
um and i think my life where it is today
is just right where it should be so i
think i'm okay
um but i thought i was going to be a
doctor that academically was not in the
cards for me i switched to focus to be
an economics degree i didn't quite know
what to do with that i was fortunate
that
um at career day at usc which is my alma
mater
i came across a lobbyist i found myself
interviewing for jobs at la county
mayor's office at the la county board of
supervisors offices
and you know the do-gooder in me
wanted to be a part of something if it
was not in medicine then maybe it was in
politics
and so i started working for
a very highly regarded latina politician
in la county
and it was really tough going because
she had high expectations
and very few people were ever meeting
those expectations but it was such a
great learning environment and i i have
to tell you there were a lot of
cuts and bruises having worked in that
office but i learned a tremendous amount
um but at the end of the day i realized
it was disconnected from
my stem background i have a passion for
the sciences it was just
it didn't feel like what i should be
doing and so i wanted to go back to
business school
find a way to get but he spent a pretty
long time there right it wasn't just you
know a month or two
right right i was there for about three
and a half years um
finished i had a great experiences
at the tender age of 21 22 years old i
was
managing a 750 million dollar
lac uic hospital construction project
co-managing that with the urban planning
deputy i was put in
leadership roles for urban planning
projects economic redevelopment
so i was in a way helping the community
and the constituency
it just wasn't what i thought it was
going to be but i did see the
the impact of the work we were doing but
again disconnected from the sciences
so it was important for me to go back
and feel reconnected to
uh science and math and so you know
thinking back to business school
hey i want to go to business school use
that to leverage into a career
in science and math and again don't know
what that looks like i just know i'm
going to get to the next rung
and figure it out when i get there and
when i did
so sorry if i continue before we
continue to that part
you you're at the intersection you're at
a sort of a junction in life and you're
saying i
yes i spent it i had a wonderful time
here working on these incredible
projects but i feel that my heart is
someplace else my true passion and my
you know my progression throughout my
career is going to be someplace else
i'm curious about this decision to go to
business school and not i mean obviously
business school it's a wonderful
experience but
you know going being at university
myself
it is a dilemma that a lot of people
have right business school it's
it's not just the financial burden of it
but it's also the time that you spend on
it
and a lot of people are wondering what's
the right path and
for you that was a that was your path as
you were transitioning careers
walk me through a little bit about the
thought process back then of why you
enroll in business school
three and a half years after you're in
the you're in the market
well i for me it was a journey because i
was
uh not very happy in the political role
because again
very connected from my core and
so i was trying to find alternative
roles and it just was not working out
for me because every
every conversation or informational
discussion i had
always came back to the fact that they
did not understand how
a job in politics and government
translated into
a job in the private sector or in
banking or anything of this sort and
the feedback that i was getting from a
lot of the individuals i spoke to said
you know what maybe you should try
to go back to business school and get a
degree where you're academically trained
in the principles of
how a business is run how businesses
operate and that will allow you to at
least get a foot in the door
and at that point i said you know what
i'd like to try that
i want i'm uh you know i'm hungry i'm a
hard worker i'm going to
do anything that i can do in order to
get my foot in the door because once i
get there
i know i'll be fine and so that
confidence carried me through
the guidance and advice of many people
carried me through
and that's how i find myself going to
business school so
now you're uh now you're running a
company and the mk insights tell me a
little bit about what you're trying to
do there and how
you're now bridging that gap with with
stem
and and your other passions to also
helping well so
excuse me um mka insights it's a
management consulting firm
which um for those who don't know and i
didn't know i think i
uh arrived at this point in my life late
um it's a consulting firm that works
with
managers business leaders executives
business owners
and the way that i describe it is we
like to work with people at the top of
the pyramid helping them
solve their toughest business challenges
so do you want to go to market in europe
do you want to launch a disruptive new
technology do you want to expand
in asia pacific those are the kinds of
business challenges that people at the
top of the company are often
faced with and so those are the kinds of
things that we enjoy doing
now we also have a very specific
focus or industry focus um coming from
the sciences
we love technology we love science so we
like to stay with the high science high
technology
verticals so we work with clinical
diagnostic companies medical device
companies
life sciences tools biologics
manufacturing tools
cell and gene therapy um so those are
kind of the
the verticals that we serve and again
whatever business challenge that they
have
we love taking on so that's what we're
working on as a company
and it stays focused with stem and the
great thing about it is we
get to experience the innovation that
this industry has to offer and it
really fuels us and keeps us going we
are part of some fantastic conversations
whether it's cobia 19 related whether
it's stem and cell and gene therapy
related
and as of late we've started getting
conversations and dialogues with company
in the aerospace sector
wow and we're really really excited
about the kinds of innovation the
the boundary pushing technology and
thought that is occurring in the high
science high technology
sectors that we serve so we're really
excited about it now are these long-term
engagements short-term engagements uh
just pay me a picture a little bit of
what what a tangible part work that you
can do so i'm coming in let's say let's
say i'm a biologist and i have a company
that i'm offering some product and i
also want to
now offer it to europe not just the
united states so i assume that i would
be able to come to you and say listen i
i've been having i'm wondering about
what is the best
way to do this so i'm having trouble
penetrating the market maybe you can
help me price or you can help me think
through my product better
are those the types of things people
come with exactly so that is an exact
um case study that we did uh or exact
engagement that we did um so we
work with companies that want
to expand into europe and so we'll do an
evaluation
of their current footprint uh we'll do
our own market research uh discovery
look at their capabilities i mean we ask
a ton of questions and that goes back to
one of the core tenants which is
education i mean we can't
in good conscious put together a plan
that says you should do this
without knowing as much as we can about
the current
industry dynamics the regional dynamics
the company its strengths and
capabilities
uh its limitations you know management
challenges and the like
and once we get that holistic picture
developed
then we have an iterative discussion
with those business leaders and say hey
we think this is the direction that's
right for you guys
is that in line with what you would like
to see happen and
it isn't a plan that we concoct in
isolation and say go do this and it's
completely unrealistic
we do it in partnership with our clients
who
you know need to own the management
decisions once we leave because the
whole
goal of working with our clients is to
enable them
and empower them to do this long after
we leave because paying a consultant
to be a part of your management team can
become extremely
uh expensive and so we don't want to do
that to our clients we want to have an
impact we want to have a measurable
impact
and we want to teach them a few things
along the way that they should retain
uh as part of their own business growth
journey well
okay then that's just incredible a quick
question before we have to wrap up and
ask
the most important question but how do
you retain knowledge within an
organization like this so you're
so you said before case study and then
he changed it to
an engagement but but it really it are
these are case studies that at the end
you go to business school and you study
these things as case studies about how
do you take
a certain a certain problem and you
tackle it through different directions
and you see what the optimal
outcome is but how do you retain that
knowledge within an organization because
these
things must be coming up that are
reminding you of previous things that
happened
and maybe one partner dealt with one
problem and another partner is dealing
with a similar problem
how does that knowledge retained
throughout an organization
well we write everything down so we like
to document what we've done in the past
because one of the the very first
questions that we ask
is who's done this before so this is one
of the
business school 101 questions that you
learn on day
when you're doing case study evaluation
you look around the room you look at
your team and go who's done this before
who knows something about this
so in order for us to be able to ask
that question we document
what our work efforts have been and then
we'll reflect back on prior engagements
and use those as a case study to
document our new clients um
efforts that's wonderful okay so so you
know 20 minutes go back very very
quickly but i have to ask the most
important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and you warned me but not but not enough
ahead in advance
so so this is not a huge commitment but
i'd still love to know
how how you how you think about yourself
or how you would like others to think
about you
um so the first one comes to mind fairly
easily i'm a problem solver
um i like problems i mean it can be mine
someone else's doesn't matter my brain
is constantly on so i love a good
problem
um and then the other uh
words describe me are i don't know how
this is an
exact word but i appreciate brevity so
you know make your point get it across
use as few words as possible
we've all got lots of things to do so
be uh mindful of your time and i i don't
know if there's a third word does it
describe me i mean
i am what i am i guess i'm very honest
i'm very transparent um
there's not a lot of things that i hide
and i pride myself on that
um because i i really stink at lying
and i've learned that lesson a really
long time ago so
um i'm forced to be honest and i
appreciate that in others as well
kiran thank you very much for the
honesty and for sharing your journey
this was wonderful
and i can't wait to share this with the
world thank you very much
thank you so much i appreciate it thanks
for having me
hey